今度は管理上ですお前たちは夏と言えば何が丘仮想
まつりだまつりっとなもいろんなも水を飲んでは夏休みライバルがサーバーざまな祭り
が各地でかなり行われているそうねつといえば釣り出さなぜいつか君たち何を買います
かた予想しかないっしょ
これを待ってるまぁ結局だらその序文でナチュラ
夏といえばコレだよなぁか違いねはーい
良いゴールよな祭りやのヒチョルが理由で醍醐味だ
かき氷を食べと思うんですけどもあ今回保全に王道の3署にズームしたんですけども
こちらの王道の刺し1番目あうルアーはちょうど3種類金が主な凰壮中木グリとと思う
んですかき氷のフレーバーとともですねもうみんな寝るんですよ僕んで迷わず腐敗が
好きだったんですけどもなんと最近ですねなんとなんとね
飛んで同じ欲しいだけますよ本当かは分からないそれ聞いた話だから何とも言えないん
ですけどもかき氷のシロップ全部味が同じらしいです
俺はそれを聞いた時ビックリしたよなんかネットにもなんかほぼ確定的な情報があった
らしくて裏を見てもあの原材料名のところ違うのは色とか色素とかそれ以外は全部成分
同じなので下手したらねマジで音色が違うだけで味が全部同じなるかもしれません真実
かどうかは俺は知らないそれを確かめるために
俺がいるんだ
んもしですよこれが3つとも同じ味だったら末尾に入れたいところだよ私何味が好きと
か私この子が過ぎてってやつは
[音楽]
色に騙されてますねそれ本当など建ての新南陽わかんない部分いきま実際にこの俺だが
ください3つ入れてお湯の女学書したままでも味は全部当てますで俺が当てたらなぜか
毒々しくね当てられたらシロップの味は色によって違うかもしれない0同じに感じたら
俺たちは暇まで市場 c 目の街どもがすきって
ちょっと全員
ってことになっちゃうね書籍20代ではここで俺がもし全部同じ言ったらいろんな人が
バカにされちまうこれはてるよちゃんと5バースメロンは神宮ソーダーず
古浜にアスペちゃんがあるんでところでブルーハワイ味って何なんですかふっとしたら
本当に前も同じなのかもしれないんですけども
レーザー確かめていくとまず味見ですシロップだけで飲むが初めてなんですが僕
応募したら前であるベルうわーうわーこショット
毒々しい色ですねできれば飲みたくないで下味を1個ずつ覚えてその後目隠しして全部
当てていきますね運用する
メロン揺れする
[音楽]
あー濃いなあかろうじてウロの字しますメロンなメロンの味をするハワイ味って皆普通
に言うけど実際みんなブルーハワイなんて食ったことないしは角栄の生き物かもしれ
ないですよね
あっはぁかろうじで blue eyed しますブルー相生で一番好きなんでブルー
オファーの女子ます
うーんいけるじゃ分多分いてます最後
あイチゴはは彼の一部は一部っぽいはイチゴはすごいわけですねイチゴが一番匂いが
強い
逃げた中の一部ですし整いましたお前の3時はこの今のシロップマイスター創 ing
で今が全部のシロップの味はちゃんとバッチリあってますから色を見ずに味だけで
シロップを判断していこうと思いますしゃっくりします
me
た
はいじゃあそろそろもう本当にわからないんだよではスタートですこれから出ます
はいこの人だよいます
me
いちごではないかいちごではない飲んでみます
ブルーハワイ
をメンバー
[音楽]
[拍手]
本当にねマジで樹も同じですちょっと運営費
わからないおまけ全部達成を何色になるかやってみたい
うん止め
真っ黒寝ちゃった